lr c'est devenu une formation politique
un peu déboussolées sans cap parce que
ça commence une campagne législative en
voulant montrer les biceps en 10 ans
voit imposer une cohabitation
et puis j'entends françois baroin il ya
quelques jours dire ah bah finalement on
participeraient bien aux bons projets de
loi et c'est donc ce que je vois c'est
que bien tout cela montre quoi qui a une
refondation une recomposition du paysage
politique qui est en marche
c'est le cas de le dire et on est un peu
comme en 58 ans fait avec le général de
gaulle qui rebat les cartes de la scène
politique française
et c'est très intéressant en 58 lui
nerfs parti nouvellement créée est
arrivé avec 200 députés à l'assemblée
nationale eh bien de la même façon je
peux vous dire que clairement les
candidats de la république en marche
vont faire je pense une entrée massive
ici et il y aura une autorité qu'il y
aura une majorité absolue